- [Instructor] In the video
on linkage institutions,
we talk a lot about political parties
and the various roles that they play
in the political system.
In particular, we talk
about how they are involved
in recruiting candidates.
And as we will talk about in this video,
we'll think about how candidates
are actually chosen to
represent a political party.
And we also talk about,
in that video on linkage institutions,
how political parties are
involved in voter mobilization,
which is a fancy way of saying,
hey getting people to vote,
getting people energized
about the election,
to actually get to the polls.
Sometimes going as far as getting buses,
transporting them to the polling stations.
And campaign management.
Campaign
management.
And one thing that is really
interesting to appreciate
and it's really the focus of this video,
is that both of these things
have evolved over time.
So for example, George Washington,
the first President of the United States,
he was not affiliated with any party
and our first two presidential elections
had no party association.
But as soon as we get
to the election of 1796,
we start to see the
development of faction.
You have Hamilton on one side,
becomes head of the Federalist Party
and on the other side,
headed by Madison,
you have the Democratic-Republican Party.
Democratic- Republican.
And there's a nice irony to this
because it was exactly those two gentlemen
that not too far before 1796,
if we go to the late 1780s,
and their attempt to get
the Constitution ratified
in the Federalist Papers,
they argue against faction.
How faction can be bad for a government,
for a nation.
But they were the ones that
led the split into faction
and the split into parties.
And from that time for over 100 years,
all the way until we
get to the early 1900s,
early 1900s,
you have some situations
where the party leadership
might pick candidates
and some situation where the
party members pick candidates
and conventions.
And so you have party leadership,
leadership slash members
who gets a hand pick.
Hand pick candidates.
So this part of the process
was not so broadly democratic.
Especially when we get to
the second half of the 1800s.
You have very strong party leaders,
often called party bosses.
Who almost had the individual power
to pick candidates to represent
one party or another.
But in the early 1900s,
there was a movement to say
hey, you know what?
This is not so democratic
to handpick the candidates
that people have to choose from.
And so this is when you start to have
the direct primary system.
Where to choose the candidates
that represent one party or another,
you will hold elections.
And those elections
could be closed primaries
where you have to be a
registered Republican
to vote for who represents
Republican party.
Or registered Democrat
to see who represents
the Democratic party.
But they also have open primaries
where anyone could vote
in the Democratic primary
or anyone could vote in
the Republican primary.
And this is happening to this day.
Now, this change that has happened
over roughly the last 100 years,
you could imagine this has changed
the power dynamic between the parties
and the candidates.
For this first over 100 years,
the party is where a lot of the power was.
But once you start having
the direct primary,
it becomes a lot more about
candidate centered campaigns.
Where things become much more about
the position and the
personality of the candidate
than maybe as much about
the party platform.
And because of that,
it has become more common
in the last 100 or so years
where even if someone is
a registered Republican,
they might vote the other way.
Or if someone is a registered Democrat,
they might vote the other way
if a candidate is particularly appealing.
For example, John F. Kennedy
was the Democratic candidate
for President in 1960.
But many Republican Irish
Catholics voted for him.
Similarly, there's a group of folks
known as the Reagan Democrats.
Who are famous for despite
their party affiliation
with the Democrats,
voted for President Reagan.
And that was all around this idea
that it was more about the candidate,
especially at the presidential level
than it is about the party.
Now just as how the
candidate picking process
has evolved over time,
so has the voter mobilization
and the campaign management.
In the early days,
a lot of the voter mobilization,
in fact, if we think about the late 1800s
where you have this party boss structure,
you had people sometimes
going so far as even
giving people things
in order to go and vote
for one candidate or another.
Or exerting some type of pressure.
The late 1800s,
or the second half of the 1800s,
especially in places like Chicago
and New York
were sometimes infamous for
not, the necessarily cleanest elections.
But as you get into the 20th century,
especially the second
half of the 20th century,
and now the 21st century,
things have become much,
much more sophisticated.
So if we go to the 20th century,
you have significant use of mass media,
mass media.
And as you go into TV and newspaper,
radio, and newspaper
has always been a factor
in political elections
going all the way back to the founding
of the United States.
And then as you go into the 21st century,
things have gotten a lot more targeted.
Obviously you can have email campaigns.
You can start to leverage social media.
And the 21st century in particular,
things like email
campaigns and social media
has allowed for very
specific targeting to voters.
What do I mean by targeting?
Well, let's say you really
care about economic issues
while your cousin who lives across town
really cares about social issues.
The same candidate,
instead of sending both
of you the same email,
might send you a targeted message
that speaks to what you care about.
And this has actually become
very, very sophisticated
in the last few years.
I'll leave you there.
But the big takeaway here
is political parties have been around
for a while in the United States.
But they have been evolving.
In this video,
I'm not even talking
about how their platforms
have evolved.
And how their associations have evolved.
But this is talking about
how they have evolved
in terms of picking candidates.
And how that has changed
the nature of campaigns.
And also, how primarily
through the changes
in culture and the changes in technology,
how they can go about mobilizing
and managing campaigns has also changed.